what's happening there reject nation we
are here today to continue arcane
episode 8 oil and water the source of
america still recovering a little bit
feel better so we can do this hey
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the finale is up more importantly
you go ahead and hit that like button
that mean the world also uh you know the
deal full-length watch along it's really
single with the time code on our patreon
page and cover a bunch of shows over
there as well and lastly thank you to
the boys over at prepper for helping us
edit down these highlights it's a lot of
work to work around a lot of claims and
and blocks so i appreciate all the hard
work you guys keep putting in so if you
guys ever are like why isn't this in
there there's a reason why it's not in
the reaction okay they're helping us out
getting around all that
anywho let's get into action
[Music]
if you want to last in this world
you must learn to be both the fox and
the wolf
i am both those things oh i'm gonna make
it like a fox
i will give you the world child
if you prove you can take it
the world is yours
i love the ominous shadow of light
around his her mom kill her now
only one must die
let her live and you may need to kill
thousands
we can show the people we are merciful
mel was gonna be a good person mercy is
the folly of statecraft
[Music]
wow what a cut what a transition
it was all for nothing
go get her vi
[Music]
oh bye come on come on
the odds would be greatly stacked
against her in a situation like that i
mean yeah there's like a million
enforcers out
keep cutting them yeah
they're gonna clean up all the rest of
the bodies and leave his
who lives here
another counselor friend of yours
[Laughter]
she's from the undercity
so i see
could we have a word caitlyn
are you perhaps a lesbian
not in this house
you and your friend can address the
council yourselves
i'd suggest you prepare accordingly what
vibrate approach the council awesome
i was going to kick all their asses
sway them all without saying a word
man everyone just turns to this guy this
guy holds the real power here
she won't die
doctor
she can't
i understand
wow
i got emotional nipple chills
she's even scarier in the light
protect the city not burn it to the
ground it's not conjecture it's a fact
weapons can't be unmade and they are
always used
very true oh yeah i left her
wow
oh this is not
this is not ideal oh no
you know
you're stronger than you think
it will only get worse
these nightmarish distortions are so
well done incredibly effective stuff
get lost pervert
what are you doing on this side of the
river i wanted to offer my assistance to
the citizens of the undercity but it
seems i'm
unwelcome
what is it
we're having the exact same day
[Laughter]
i don't know how i'm gonna get down
there with my leg bust student well
you're holding my ride
team up you two i want you to succeed
here jayce to grace the world with
hextech but if you don't accept certain
realities i fear you'll end up like
general police slaughtered with your
eyes closed
goddammit jace just keeps getting
influenced
councillors this is vi
she was born in the undercity
even though we failed her in
countless ways
she risked everything to show me what
life is really like down there
people are starving
i really hope they get together
i don't care what y'all say i ship them
this jinx has the gemstone
then we have to go in by force that
could trigger war there are good people
down there
bad ones too even if we wanted to invade
they have shimmer
we have hextech oh [ __ ]
damn it
jace you don't know war
i do
it must be our last resort
there may be a diplomatic solution but
your naked mom said
she told me to go to war
we'll make a new plan we have to try
we tried okay it wasn't enough top side
and bottom oil and water that's all
there is
what about us oil and water oh no
don't say that
do yourself a favor cupcake
go back to that big shiny house of yours
and just
forget me okay
no
no go after her chase her god damn it
[ __ ] caitlyn
[Music]
wow that too with the ships behind them
oh yeah go for it man go for it go on
spiderman yeah yes you're doing it
tom cruise run
don't hurt yourself oh my gosh
afraid you're gonna get carried away
yeah
victor
i was inspired by your
[Music]
everything you do inspires me
oh god
please don't exchange her in the process
[Music]
oh this is bad
we don't even know what she was working
on
no
no
it
can't
she a part of you
oh god heal my show [ __ ]
oh
oh that thing's alive
you said you were tired of doing nothing
that's the only sensible thing that came
out of anyone's mouth tonight
i'm not a vigilante
no
you're a victim
gauntlets
yeah
[Music]
with the snap of the lights [ __ ] balls
can you raise your hand in the boardroom
we built them for mining the fishers
i use it for punching people
yup yup upgrade
silko controls the undercity with
shimmer
shut down his supply and it's only a
matter of time before his own people
turn on him and how do we do that take
out his manufacturing facilities hit him
hard and fast before he can react
oh dude i'll get [ __ ] pumped
up
we got a deal
what a build up what a like a great man
this is all like just so coalescing
together so so perfectly
oh damn it's going down holy
man
damn dude hammer of justice
damn it
no
crap no
crap
we're waiting for this
oh second nipple chills
oh
wow
[Music]
wow he's really improved those
shimmer thugs
oh yeah i'm going back to like the third
episode
[Music]
sweet
sweet nice
dude
dude
come on
[Music]
yeah that's why jace works out so much
oh
cool
oh so great oh so great god this is so
great
oh man you got like an x-ray shot there
yeah it's like mortal kombat
wow
i'm an inventor
respect the power of science
oh [ __ ] balls
oh no oh that just took
and that kid knew the risk when he took
this job
third nipple chills
three-act nipples three-headed berry
three different reasons
gotta get you a third nipple
oh god why didn't he just have an
instant death
oh this is war man
yeah
like it or not they struck first
v should be in that shower with you
after this you're going to need your own
mel's mom like massage bath
she'll never forget you v
[Music]
that is the nicest shower
oh
[ __ ] oh damn
oh she in the room right now oh my god
oh no
no wow
oh what an ending
wow what a good episode
oh
oh man oh no balls
balls mcgee
so freaking
everyone put a rope around jason paul
oh god you go that side you go to that
side we all pull at the same time
[Laughter]
man what a good episode what a damn good
episode i love seeing it all just come
together you know like as we we were
talking about we used to way back in the
day
you know all those episodes ago way back
on episode one last week
we were like uh tilt over and and the
council meetings were never really that
interesting to like they were
it was more like i'm getting the
information but i'm not necessarily
emotionally gripped by any of this yeah
and then now to be here
words like all that was so necessary and
so important and my god everything is
intense and matters yeah yeah and
everything going on at the council is
messed up and anguished and they're all
these conflicting voices and now you got
mel's mom coming in the picture pushing
war and then they even flesh out mel
some more because i always i was under
the impression mel's uh you know a [ __ ]
and here you get the
the whole thing of because this show
deals a lot with like themes of
influence yeah and espec and then you're
dealing with the parental influence with
mel and her mom and
just like
going through the flashback of this this
uh
looming ominous figure
this stature that her mom is that has
always cast a shadow over her
even to this day even though 10 years
apart
but how she was the one going look i
know we've made some changes but
we shouldn't go to war yeah like that's
not the right way to do this guys yeah
too and the way they have the
conversation about all this and visual
storytelling you know like
because yeah i'm like in it every moment
i'm feeling whatever the show wants me
to feel which is so strange because i'm
like i just keep falling for everything
yes absolutely because when like jay
because when vi is like uh with the
council
and saying you guys just don't get it do
you like so there's no negotiating here
you gotta you gotta take silko out
there's no if ands or buts about this
you gotta take him out and all that but
that would lead to war if we're going
after the undercity
so then when jace and vai are teaming up
i'm like oh yeah let's go let's kick
some ass man let's just get it done and
then when their weapon ass or whopping
ass you're feeling it but the second
that child gets hit you're like oh [ __ ]
the reality is about the battle with
warriors yeah and the reality of silko's
operation is that probably he employs
all the kids
this is gonna be so much uglier than you
expected yeah so it's like did they make
the right to jace make the right
decision because jace is just this
character who has been this pawn
to
literally every this guy has been
nothing but been given advice and he's
just been
the
confused
time and he keeps just trying to do the
right thing
because he's in this power position he
never asked to be in
and it just seems like no matter what
choice he makes it resorts into
something terrible
that's the irony it feels like is he had
what felt like more tangible power
before he was given the official power
position and now it's all bureaucracy
and now it's all distracting from
what he's actually there to do and yeah
i thought that stuff got really uh
yeah has gotten increasingly
gripping and then just the debate of
what to do and i love uh how
that went how that played with vi and
caitlyn sort of having their spat and
splitting off and i thought i was just
gonna go back to the undercity but no
she just goes directly
to jace which i thought was a nice
little nuance too because it's like you
know she yeah clearly was listening and
she clearly recognized that one thread
of him that's still different from the
rest of the council but she's acting in
a way to try and protect caitlyn
and uh yeah like watching them fight
side by side was
it was so cathartic but also yeah like
it was building tension within me at the
same time it was releasing it almost
yeah
well they're good at they're good at
using all their elements that they have
with an animation medium
to get you to feel
what they need you to feel in the
character shoes at that moment
because like when they are getting their
vengeance you're feeling that yeah and
then when they're dealing with the
consequences of of a child's life being
stripped away all off of just i'm caught
up in the moment of killing yeah you
know one target to the next here we go
yeah
yeah
it sucks
it's it's a it's an interesting nuanced
layer here so that's what i like is
there's always this gray area even even
when
i forget mel's mom's name at this moment
but even mel's mom you know i love how
she she's like a classic warrior vibe
like she seems from an earlier century
yeah um
and i i love how she
uh
her conversation with jace is
even there like
make some points you know yeah solid
points about this whole thing yeah
there's a reason she holds the position
that she has for so long see the thing
about jace
of why it doesn't bug me because i'm
like i get it dude i don't know who the
[ __ ] to listen to either anymore yeah
every one ally of accounts is gone now
so everyone has a point and i don't know
who to listen to yeah absolutely uh so
yeah that's why they do a great job at
thrusting you into perspectives here
uh yeah then we got like heimerdinger
his the one friend who's uh now with
echo helping him out there's no way i
mean i heard they announced season two
already so there's no way they could
wrap all this up in 40 minutes
this is this is the act one of a much
greater story absolutely i'm all in for
it uh because yeah they have that with
heimerdinger and echo
and i like the path heimerdinger has
chosen he's like
it's cool origin story of him this guy
who was like top of the council and now
now an outcast going to be like a
like a vigilante healer yeah going to be
among the people who hate the very thing
that he created yeah and trying to give
back to them now that he's been you know
that he's seen the opposite side of the
upper hand true from piltover and i like
that theme too that that comes out
through like vi talking to caitlyn on
the bed about like we we used to pretend
we were bigger and bigger monsters and
stuff like that and throughout this
episode i mean you know you've got jinx
being
worked on you've got victor
experimenting on himself and these awful
consequences coming out of both of those
things and it's got me pretty like
actually quite nervous to see what
happens to the both of them because i
can only imagine this is going to propel
jinx that much further away from
everybody even silke like she in the
brief flashes of jinx's character that
we still got even though she was
incapacitated for a lot of this it seems
like she is definitely
kind of wayward in between all of her
different influences and i don't know
which direction to expect her to go
other than her own perhaps well this
episode really showed that soko
cares heavily about jinx
he loves her only like a father would a
daughter though or a father with
conflicting feelings for his
stepdaughter
who is
definitely of age
i always say this [ __ ] the best of you
guys
you know yeah but
and that and that's in the moment you
know yeah obviously he uses her and
manipulates her yeah he does all those
things he's a he's an abusive stepfather
to say the least uh emotionally abusive
and physically in some ways too um i'm
not saying sexually but you know
physically emotionally in some ways for
sure
uh
so
though though when he saw her body you
could tell he was incredibly distraught
like that conversation they were having
with
tough girl with arm
yeah yeah
you know the that the guy who was trying
to um
it was undermining her position and all
that to do with the tatted up face jaw
guy
yeah yeah he he had a good point about
like once jinx went down his spine
became like jelly like so yeah and you
see that he he's very weak towards when
she's in suffrage or pain or the thought
of losing her like he
was emotionally distraught by this and
he cares
so even though he needs her and uses her
for his own gain and purpose
he still also really cares about this
the human being you know and that just
makes it more conflicting because
there are parts i wasn't i wasn't 100 on
that i thought maybe he he just always
had user i didn't think there was an
actual real layer i didn't think there
was a real level of he genuinely has a
heart for her and cares but this episode
establishes that making
all this that much more worse and i
thought the nightmarish use of jinx made
it that much more clear-cut too
of
it was always clear but it was even more
clear with the whole threat of
uh caitlyn and vi's life you know
that just the philosophical stance of
your average enforcer has
and how she's always viewed the
enforcers how that would overshadow
everything about oh yeah that's just
you're you're siding with the enemy
you're a traitor to everything that we
stand for now advise the villain and uh
yeah it was all intense intense stuff in
that that ending moment right there just
showing up at her place
so okay what's the far fetch right okay
i know i'm always like wrong about it
like who's going to hook up and [ __ ]
that's not far it seems like they're
really implying that there's a possible
romance between them right or is it
another or is it a sisterly connection
between caitlyn and and by because i'm
getting the impression that there's a
potential for romance i could see it
either way but i get i pick up that
thread yeah like there's some kind of
attraction beyond just you know oh yeah
we get along really well like there's
something about their body language and
there's something about the way that
they draw the emotionality and i mean
this show is
of any animation i've ever seen the show
is especially good at pulling like you
said emotion out of both its visual
language but also out of just
its character expressions
and i mean yeah there's something
very intimate about the two of them that
to me feels like there's at least some
kind of undercurrent of attraction i
hope so yeah i i mean like
not even in a silly way i'm like yeah it
would be great if they went like they
seemed like they would be great for each
other
and then of course we got hey buddy i'll
feed you in a bit
and then of course we got ourselves
uh we got ourselves one second oh damn
it's just got some information
um
[ __ ] gotta afford a text message like oh
[ __ ]
uh
uh was it shimmer
victor uh
victor man
like that's what i mean the show's so
good just making me go i feel what
you're feeling oh and i also feel the
other feeling
without being seen both
when he starts running i was like yeah
and then the second uh skye starts
walking in was like
no
what are you doing uh that was that was
her she got dusted right that was
yeah that's what it looked like out of
that because yeah that looked like ash i
mean i don't know how any of this magic
[ __ ] works i don't know if she's like
stuck in some other weird dimension or
is in that cube i don't know i mean
but the implication is that she's dead
but you guys will probably be like
you're wrong greg
only greg though even though i think
she's dead i would suggest not putting
your keyboards this high up by the way
for space bar because
i
um yeah yeah so that was uh
that's what i mean with victor i was
right there with him the whole time yeah
well that's a great again there's a
great imbuing of that principle with it
whenever they're messing with hextech
they always keep you
mindful of that law of equivalent
exchange yeah and it comes and goes in a
lot of different ways and this was like
the most overt and most painful of them
yet
well it seems like they're building up
via to be the new vander right
yeah it seems like even like the whole
foreshadowing with the gauntlets that
they did in three and then here
and then the fact that they're trying to
take out silko that it could potentially
end with
vi and jinx being the leaders or just vi
i have
i could see jinx going either way but
definitely at least vi yeah i don't know
jinx is all righted up now with shimmer
yeah
i don't know shimmer right is that what
they put in her yeah oh yeah yeah
i mean and and who who knows what else
that doctor's using but yeah i mean at
least shimmer's involved so i mean maybe
she and victor will wind up being
similar
because i couldn't like it seemed like
that was his leg
like organically changed by shimmer
right or is that like a robot leg that
he's imbuing with
[ __ ] i don't know man
yeah even that little white orb that
that like rubik's cube hex orb that he
keeps playing with is like warping and
changing it's
it's like
literal matter configuration yeah
so
it's fascinating
and painful
it's all very painful
a very rewarding way
all right guys well
let's let's end this video
but hey uh make sure to subscribe and
click that bell leave your thoughts down
below hit that like button
and we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]